breaking news bei bild am abend und wir
beginnen mit einem neuen handfesten
politskandal der vor wenigen minuten
konsequenzen hatte seit ende februar
erst war stephan mayer neuer
generalsekretär der csu der christlich
sozialen union konservativ schneidig wie
es sich für einen csu general gehört der
mann an seiner seite aber jetzt nach gut
zwei monaten ist schon wieder schluss
meyer ist soeben zurückgetreten er hatte
journalisten massiv gedroht nachdem sie
herausgefunden hatten dass er sich im
privatleben offenbar nicht so christlich
verhält wie es der parteinahme vor gibt
und wie er es vor spielt auch wenn die
rücktrittserklärung sich etwas anders
liest aus gesundheitlichen gründen habe
ich heute den parteivorsitzenden der csu
gebeten mich von meiner aufgabe als
generalsekretär zu entbinden in einem
aufgrund einer eklatant rechtswidrigen
berichterstattung geführten gespräch mit
einem journalisten der bunte habe ich
möglicherweise eine wortwahl verwendet
die ich rückwirkend für nicht angemessen
betrachtet würde das bedauere ich sehr
und um diese wortwahl handelte es sich
ich werde sie vernichten ich werde sie
bis an ihr lebensende verfolgen
unterstehen sie sich mich je wieder zu
kontaktieren das gilt für die ganze bild
wir sehen uns vor gericht klingt wie
drohungen aus einem psychothriller aber
diese aussagen kommen von csu politiker
stefan meyer der süder freund und
generalsekretär der csu wollte reporter
von bild münchen und bunte so davon
abhalten über ihn zu berichten
die wortwahl ich mach euch fertig ist
nun wahrlich nicht besonders klug also
ich kenne eigentlich die meisten die
allermeisten journalisten selbst aus dem
pulver wie wir mal mit denen anständig
spricht und erläutert warum bestimmte
dinge vielleicht nicht so toll sind wenn
es jetzt nicht gerade die politischen
großen sünden sind dass wir dann
zumindest mit sich reden lassen und
vielleicht sogar verständnis haben was
war passiert münchner medien hatten
berichtet dass meyer offenbar seinen 80
unehelichen sohn verheimlicht hat noch
nie habe er den jungen zu gesicht
bekommen habe jahrelang keinen cent
gezahlt dann die vaterschaft
abgestritten erfolglos so die
journalistin von bunte mayer hatte in
interviews immer wieder betont wie
wichtig ihm sein eigener vater war wie
sehr er seine kindheit geprägt hatte für
den eigenen sohn wollte er diese rolle
offensichtlich nicht einnehmen ein
kommunikationsdesaster
uneheliche kinder sind erst mal durchaus
normal mag für die betroffenen nicht so
toll sein aber gilt auch unter politik
und der für politiker nicht mehr als
eine riesen sünde der unterschied ist
allerdings wenn wir über politiker
sprechen die eine bestimmte moral sehr
stark heraus gehoben haben wenn diese
erwischt werden und trotzdem noch
dagegen wehren dass man dazu was bringt
dann wird's dann zumindest schon mal
peinlich und es in der vergangenheit
immer wieder gesehen ja es gibt
schlimmeres als das aber besonders
angenehm wird es natürlich auch mich
gerade bunte leitet nun juristische
schritte ein will sich nicht gefallen
lassen dass politiker kritische
journalisten unter druck setzen gabe
drohen vielleicht vernichtete er nicht
die journalisten sondern seine eigene
karriere
kurz vor beginn dieser sendung hat meyer
seinen rücktritt eingereicht
starker tobak das alles gehen wir zu
blöd münchen chef daniel kremer daniel
das ging schnell meyer spricht von einer
persönlichen entscheidung wie glaubhaft
ist das
grüß gott aus münchen erstmalig glaube
dass wenn er die persönliche
entscheidung jetzt nicht kurz vor knapp
selber getroffen hätte dass markus söder
eben diese entscheidung dann doch
grundsätzlich abgenommen hätte man darf
ja nicht vergessen dass markus söder
selbst ausgebildeter journalist beim
bayerischen rundfunk es jetzt ist meyer
ja nicht der erste politiker der ein
uneheliches kind hat warum hat er so
heftig reagiert
das ist uns eigentlich nicht klar der
anlass für die geschichte war ja nun
dass meyer selber herausgestellt hat wie
wichtig sein vater vielen es meyer kommt
aus dem und vielleicht noch
konservativen landkreis den es in
deutschland gibt aus dem landkreis
altötting und hat doch daneben in
interviews zur bundestagswahl immer
wieder als vor bild was ist ihr vorbild
immer wieder seinen vater genannt mein
vater er hat mein leben geprägt mein
großes vorbild ist mein vater und dann
kamen wir journalisten unter anderem
bild münchen und auch die bunte halt
eben hinweise dass wir das mit der
eigenen vaterschaft gar nicht so genau
und vor allem nicht so gut nimmt wie er
seinen eigenen vater sieht dass das nun
dahin führt hat uns selber tatsächlich
überrascht weil das ist ja sprache wie
aus aus diktaturen der sich meyer dort
bedient hat warum ihn das tatsächlich
dazu gebracht hat da weiß man nicht da
muss man sich tatsächlich fragen was was
in seinem kopf vorgegangen ist nun ist
ja gerade mal zwei monate lang
generalsekretär gewesen die meisten
menschen in deutschland kennen ihn
wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht richtig
ist er auch in der vergangenheit schon
aufgefallen
ja wenn man sich jetzt noch einmal
ansieht hatte man ja über die jahre
immer schon wieder ausraster er ist
einmal auf der wiesn mit einem türsteher
an einem riesenzelt aneinander geraten
weil er einlass begehrte in das zelt man
erzählt sich mit seinem ausweis mit dem
parlamentarier ausweis den hat es nicht
gegeben dann wird es handgreiflich er
hat eine alkoholfahrt hingelegt die dann
vor gericht auch zu einem ausraster
führte wo er den staatsanwalt
beschimpfte er hat ist einmal erwischt
worden dass er die besetzungslisten im
bundestag gefälscht hat er hat sich
eintragen lassen für eine sitzung da
gibt es ja geld und war dann nicht da um
dann erst kürzlich ist herausgekommen
dass seine schwester im zuge der masken
beschaffung des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums eine
provision bekommen hat er hatte das
weitergeleitet dann gab es einen kleinen
skandal er hat dann behauptet dass er
natürlich erst gar nicht gewusst hätte
dass seine schwester dafür geld bekommen
hat er hätte das erst auf nachfrage
bewusst wenn man sie jetzt mal so
aneinander liegt ist es schon
verwunderlich
dass er dann doch noch so eine große
karriere gemacht ja in der tat da fragt
man sich wie söder markus söder diesen
mann überhaupt zu einem seiner engsten
mitarbeiter machen konnte
es heißt aus der csu mal dass die beiden
sich sich menschlich nahe stehen haben
sich auch gut verstehen auch wenn sie
schon unterschiedliche inspektoren der
csu abbilden meyer ist deutlich deutlich
konservativer als markus söder selbst
die sich alle mit regenbogen es zeigt
und für die rechte von schwulen und
lesben eintritt da würde ich meine jetzt
nicht unbedingt als erster sehen der mit
der regenbogenfahne haben cs denen als
er im voraus läuft trotzdem hat es
zwischen den zwei alphatieren menschlich
immer gut funktioniert und silber
brauchte jemanden in der partei der
aufräumt und der eine gewisse stärke hat
und dass diese stärke und diese
durchsetzungsfähigkeit bei meyer in
manchen momenten
weit über das ziel hinaus geht und nicht
nur in diesem sondern auch in der
vorherigen episoden hat söder
wahrscheinlich einfach nicht gewusst
wird natürlich jetzt ein problem für sie
also nach gut zwei monaten ist schon
wieder schluss
csu-generalsekretär meyer soeben
zurückgetreten aktuelle informationen
dazu von dann gegeben hat danke daniel
sehr gerne